rome venise peas jany rêve depuis des
années c'est donc un départ de montréal
direction rome pour une escapade de kiev
mais arrivé à destination sur le
kérosène
aucune trace de sa bêtise que faire
première chose j'en dois remplir un
rapport de perte ou comptoir de son
transporteur aérienne c'est lui qui est
responsable du retard ou de la perte de
sa valise deuxième chose magazine et
bien sûr mais ce n'est pas le temps de
refaire sa garde-robe
elle n'a droit qu'au strict minimum
puisque sa valise est susceptible de
réapparaître cri très important pour
être remboursé jeanne doit conserver
toutes les factures de ses achats j'en
reviens tu oublies toujours aucune
nouvelle de sa valise et sa compagne
aérienne ne lui répond pas at-elle un
recours oui elle pu porter plainte à
l'office des transports du canada
gratuit pas besoin d'un avocat est le
fils peut obliger le transporteur à
l'indemniser à noter le maximum qu'un
voyageur peut réclamer est d'environ
2000 $ lors d'un vol international
en plus pour son voyage en partie rapt
et jeanne peut s'adresser aux petites
créances pour obtenir un dédommagement
le fin mot de l'histoire vous avez des
droits
ne laissez surtout pas un transporteur
aérien vous prendre pour une valise